this is the perfect movie to see in IMAX  we wanted to make these movies which are  unprecedented in scope and scale in IMAX  is because we felt it was the proper  format for people to view them and gets  this many shoot  they're amazing cosmic landscapes your  characters with amazing powers in them  and IMAX being the most immersive  experience available and what you see a  film  I can't imagine wanting to see this  would be any other way  [Music]  one of the unique things about an IMAX  screen is the vertical dimension  compared to the width pianist is a very  physically large character and there's  something thrilling about seeing a  character that imposing and large  standing in the same frame with our  heroes this does put a smile in my face  the best way to experience and three war  for your first time it's going to be out  of the IMAX screen  you